Hi everyone, I'm Rowi. Um, we're a bit
of a late start, but we'll start now.
Uh, so welcome to my talk. It's a 20inut
session about agent reconnaissance, what
it actually mean, and how we were able
to find thousands of agents and map down
their capabilities.
Let's start to dive in.
Uh we'll overview different platforms in
this talk. One of them would be um
Microsoft Copilot Studio. We'll also
overview agent builder by OpenAI, custom
GPT by OpenAI
and various AI middlewares, LLM runtimes
and model context protocol servers that
we find we found using open source
intelligence.
And what we found was kind of amazing.
We found tens of thousands of agents
just out there in the web. Out of them,
thousands were unauthenticated. You
could just get in and uh see what kind
of information they have out there. And
we've actually seen some incredible
stuff like sensitive documents just out
in the open or even a business tool with
really high impact. Those things are
extremely risky. So let's talk a little
bit more about what agent recon actually
means and why it matters. Well to start
this conversation we need to understand
that an agent is still an application.
Um sure it's connected to an LLM. It has
tools but it's still a traditional
application and like every application
it has breadcrumbs. It has discoverable
resources. It has endpoints API. It can
be embedded inside iframe. And so in the
same way an application is discoverable,
a agents are also discoverable through
the web. It's a subset of web discovery.
The second important thing is
that agents are highly integrated in the
enterprise.
Um a lot of agents have credentials
embedded in them. They're connected to
different enterprise data sources. they
can sometimes change um data inside the
enterprise. So in a way agents are a
gateway to your enterprise and that
makes them extremely risky and so
when we talk about discovery attackers
make use of a of different issues. Um
most of them are listed here. um they
make use of common design patterns that
I that are used when when creating
resources that expose your uh your
exposure. They make use of out of the
box config because it decreases the the
search space and we're going to talk
about it. Uh they make use of uh
platform security gaps. Um some
platforms have known issues. Um and as
we all know prompt injection for
instance is not really a solvable
problem as of now.
And another thing and this has been true
security for decades now. Security by
obscurity doesn't really work.
So let's start and overview the
different platforms. Um we'll start by
copilot studio. Now when you create a
copilot studio resource, you're
basically creating a website with an
agent embedded in there connected to
your enterprise resources and embedded
inside a chat like you see over here.
But under the hood, a URL is actually
created and this URL is comprises of
various components. Some of them have
entropy, others have more pred more
predictable. And let's just go over them
one by one. And we'll start with the
purple one that you see over here.
That's the environment.
Now, an environment is essentially a
container for your tenants enterprise
resources. And every tenant is created
with a default environment. And like you
can see over here, the default
environment is always created with the
prefix default followed by the tenant
ID. How do we get this tenant ID? Well,
turns out AD internal uh conducted a
research and they found an undocumented
Microsoft API that by giving it the
domain, you can fetch back the tenant
ID. So that's how we can resolve um the
the the environment variable. Now what
about this one? This is this is called
the solution prefix. A solution prefix
is actually created to create to um
achieve uniqueness in u the agents that
you create inside your environment. This
solution prefix is essentially an alpha
numeric string between the uh length of
uh five and eight alpha numeric
characters. So it has pretty high
entropy. However, like I said earlier,
most people is the default. And we found
that the default uh the search space is
is is kind of small. uh it comprises of
the CR prefix followed by two to three
alpha numeric strings. So it can be
fuzzed but here's the thing um it's not
the only thing that you need to that you
need to find because it's also connected
to um an agent.
So we have to find like a solution
prefix along with an agent.
Well, turns out a lot of environment are
created with some default bots or that
are pretty much common. Copilot one,
copilot two, one, two, three, test, AI,
AI bot. And by finding just one of these
along with the fuzzing that we did
earlier, you can find a solution prefix.
And once you found the solution prefix,
you can basically enumerate and find
different agents in this environment.
And again, this is something every
developer would do.
mix it match by Atlassian database
dashboard sandbox integration test dev
prods
on the industry but it's pretty easy to
fuzz and using that approach we were
able to find
tens of thousands of those agents
um taking a step further there uh we
also to took leverage of uh uh power
platform API and we're also able to
figure out whether those agents require
authentication or not and like you can
see over here um
you can also extend it um by by by using
subdomain enumeration and expand the
number of agent that you that you can
find even more and that's that's
just so you understand how much how much
of a problem that is a internal actually
had a website that by giving it a domain
you could have fetched back the tenant
ID and they had to turn it down because
it was actually abused.
Now let's move to the next platform.
Now we're going to talk about agent
builder by OpenAI. Agent Builder works
in the same way that Copilot Studio
works, but the only difference is that
the developer is in charge of the
deployment and that's exactly how it can
create an create an attack surface
because OpenAI recommends a bunch of um
GitHub repo starter kits that have
well-known names. So match that with the
fact that most agents are also deployed
using Versel and render
and the cell space of the different
addresses of the agents is pretty
limited. Add that to the fact that um
some of them also contain the branch
name and you reduce the search the
search space even more. um to check to
check if if an agent exists, you
basically need to call create session,
receive receive the client secret um
fetch check if it was verified or not.
And if it was, you've got an agent out
there.
And as you can see over here, um we we
were able to witness some of these
agents and some of them had
I think our
screen is a problem.
But essentially, we were able to see
that um those agents might actually
contain some confidential information
that was not supposed to be there.
Next, we're going to overview custom
GPTs. Uh custom GPT is a way for uh
enterprises connect to uh different uh
different GPS with different
capabilities. But the problem is that um
it's by design but everyone can see it
and by that you also increase your
attack surface. So whenever you look at
a different custom GPT you can see the
different capabilities that it has from
from the default tools. In this case you
can see that it has Python browser and
Deli. Um but it can also contain custom
connectors such as this one that uh list
all your Gmails. Now again this is by
design. It's by no means
uh traditional recon uh but it it gives
an attacker a lot of information and you
need to be aware of that.
Next we uh overviewed using open source
intelligence a bunch of AI medals and by
that I mean LLM runtimes AI gateway
model context protocol servers and we
used various methods for that. So
if you look at Shoddon for instance,
this the right one? Yeah. Okay. If you
look at Shoddon for instance and look
and you look for the well- definfined
MCP session ID, you will be able to find
hundred of thousand of just open ser of
open MCP servers. Some of them are
authenticated, some of them are not, but
they're just out out in the open. Um,
another thing we we were able to find
was using an HTML hash and we literally
found um an opened copilot API got its
swagger and it had an exposed endpoint
of purge vector DB. Now I don't really
know what they have in this vector DB
but it shouldn't be public.
Another interesting resource in GSO says
are MCP registries. MCP registers
contain a lot of information. They
contain the backend URL. They contain
different tools that the MCPU that are
available in the MCPS in in in the JSON
file. And again, it gives information
about your services. This can be
dangerous.
Now, this is actually very interesting.
Um,
back links can also be used for that.
uh as you can see in this example in
copilot studio for example uh you can
embed a copilot or an agent inside an
iframe now once you do that you
essentially created a backlink for your
agent um so we use backlink search tools
to search for
copilotstudio.microsoft.com
and that alone showed us 2500 open
agents in the web and like I said
earlier some of them were just un
unauthenticated
uh same thing with Amazon agents just
out there in the open.
Now, some notable challenges that we had
when uh when we did this exercise, uh we
had some issues with freight limiting
that we solved. Uh some issues with
headless browser finger uh
fingerprinting and like uh I described
earlier, we also had to reduce the
search space for for some of the
solution prefixes. Um, if you're
interested to learn more, uh, I can talk
about I can talk about after the
session, but it's also important to note
that we have an open source tool called
Power Pawn and you can see the committee
history over there. It's all out in the
open. Um, now up until now we talked
about discovery of agents, but why does
it actually matters? Like what's the
impact? You're going to say, "Okay, Roy,
we have guardrails. Why why do we care?"
Well, you do care because first of all,
um, attackers can still keep on probing
your agent and understand what kind of
information it has, what's the knowledge
source of it. Um, sometimes it's kind of
easy. You just need to ask for it.
Sometimes it has guardrails, sometimes
it doesn't have guardrails, and attacks
can also probe for the different tools
that exist in your system. That is
extremely risky. As you can see in this
example, um to fetch the tools, we just
have to ask for it and
add a little bit more beef to basically
confuse the different activations for
the of the guardrails.
It's not wallet proof and that's why
your agent shouldn't be public unless
intended to.
Now, to help you with that, we created
Power Pawn. PowerPoint is an open source
tool that helps you assess the posture
of your agents and identify whether
they're public or not. Um, and it
basically entails all of the information
that I just showcased in this uh in this
presentation and we'll go over different
the different models that it has. Um
so the first one is copilot studio
hunter and like we like I showcase
earlier you just give it the the the
domain name of the given u of the given
organization. It will find your tenant
ID eventually will find uh the the the
solution prefix and once it does that it
will iterate through different agents in
this environment one by one and if
they're public it will also list out the
different capabilities.
Another model that we have is a agent
builder hunter. Agent Builder Hunter
receives a list of words basically your
name of the agent and tries to identify
whether if it's public or not and if it
has any exposed endpoints.
You can see over here it actually found
some and found exposed MCP tools.
Um another model is custom GPT enter
where given a search term it showcases a
different um different custom GPTs along
with the capabilities whether if they're
default or custom and last but not least
LLM hound where given a search term that
that you're looking for the name of your
middleware um it will find AI middleares
that again are just out there in the
open you can use various shoddon filters
such as such as MC CP and you can even
give it your shoddon API key. Um and and
as you can see in this particular
example for probing, we were actually
able to find
port a swagger and a and um and a fully
exposed MCP server.
Now a couple of takeaways from this.
Everything that I showed you, nothing of
these was an actual was an actual zero
day, right? It was you can even say that
it was pretty basic but these things
happen and if you want to reduce your
the risk first of all don't make your
agent public if you if you don't need to
and don't use the default configuration
default configuration are bad it reduces
the the search space you you want to
rely on the high on high entropy the
second thing is um I highly recommend
you to use open source tools such as
power to identify whether you have uh
public endpoints or not and if you
shouldn't have close them down and I
think that one Last thing that I'd like
to add is you should add observability
to your AI because you don't know what
you don't know and that's just the way
it is.
Um, so that's it for me. I was Rowey. I
work for Zenit as a staff engineer and
yeah, it was fun.